McLoud feeds the Blue Line here's Kevin Paul sends
it right back to Nate Bastion Bastion spins away
from a check cuts the front save San and the
rebound dribbles out good opening shift from
the devil's fourth line but now a chance for Brad
marshan to break the other way for Boston Maran
into the offensive end Kevin Ball ties him up no
penalty called as the puck skips toward the front
vanich has to make a play on Charlie Coyle to
knock the puck into the corner Coy's had a really
good season the 31-year-old has 21 points already
this year for Boston here's marshand his first
year as a captain after the retirement of Patrice
berson and he flutters this one into vanich SM
geeki with poock and Jake debrusk on this top line
for Boston here's a drive from the blue line for
Mason Lorry an NHL rookie at 22 years old doesn't
always work out what a regular season they had
there oh good chance in front and a big save from
vanich on Danton Heinen who pounced on the loose
Puck the Devils have to get a little more crisp
in their own Zone we saw the first shift they came
out established a for check but played two and
A2 minutes no score Matt grizzli shot is blocked
quatra on the spin turn shoots and Van makes
another save PA clears out the loose Puck coming
back home you've got some fog you have some cobweb
so you've got to get out of it quickly and you see
the Bruins get it back to the point the quick shot
Watcher's able to pick that puck up as his stick's
not tied up right here and the youngster who's
been a surprise for the B grizzli spins away from
it he had an early season injury but he's healthy
and starting to play well grizz's pass intercepted
by John Marino who grew up a Bruins fan he feeds
and Meer shot is denied by San yeah I want to see
team when he gets that puck shoot don't try
to overthink it keep firing away eventually
now you're going to get get some opportunities
and uh maybe they'll go in the back of the net
but I think at times maybe he's trying to handle
it a little too much trying too hard poster knock
from a sharp angle makes a shot save van and he
sprawls on top of the rebound to freeze it for 17
in brat possesses 45 seconds to go to denied
by San after Jack Hughes SLI to pass inside
and now it's Johnny beer who's been killing this
entire penalty he ran out of Ste he couldn't break
away there nice set up in the high slot bumper
position for TFI first good chance in this power
play but you saw again Devil's kind of then it's
taken away by geeki for Boston he hammered Luke
Hughes geeky gets it to Van Reams he's Cs and it
bounces off the Stick of Danton Heinen Heinen was
free in front here's van rste save van rebound
score Morgan geeky puts Boston ahead with 309 n
to go in the first could not maintain possession
of the pocket and the Bruin stayed relentless on
it and they just kept moving around this one's
a nice save initially as vanichic bats it down
with the glove hand but you see Morgan geeky you
know beats Miller to the to the spot and able to
wrap around body position think he maybe kick that
puck to his Bruins come the other way Charlie Coy
shot goes wide Lindy Ruff making some tinkerings
here right off the bat Hughes finds brat one on
one he shoots and San makes the save possible
and that's certainly something that could help
you you hear about I talked about Scott neire
being a great oh it's turned over to the front
and vanich makes a save on Van re shaton Kirk
settles in he was looking for poock and geeky
lost control geeky gets it back poock controls
and Van comes down to make the save you get a
chance to get it out with the p with past knock
out there you have to get it out L right to the
front van check fre nearing the Midway point of
this game still one- nothing Boston Mercer to the
outside HS Drive save and the rebound controlled
by San no rebound from San right you got to you
got to place it perfectly maybe a foot off the
ice and hope to get a rebound as well here's
brat cutting to the front Swan kept it out comes
up ahead to team o Meer again he absorbs a hit and
wraps it around as the devils are in the midst of
a change Hughes centers p backand and swan makes
another save number two goalie in the league in
terms of save percentage so far this year here's
nio Glides it team o Myer turning around he shoots
again save made by Swingman this period's the best
Meer has looked since returning from injury he's
been very aggressive here in Period two yeah you
want to see him assertive and you know just keep
firing away with that shot get the pucks quickly
seeing a little more of that in a second when he's
going he's a guy who wants the puck on his stick
he'll take a lot of shots here's a chance for
poster knock and vanich gets to him ball holded in
hard across John Marino holds it in Marino shoots
save San rebound banging at it it's still loose in
front and Coyle just whacks at it Nemitz takes
it up top he's got space pass handcuffed Holtz
down low Meer moves it one SW got over on Mercer
Puck comes out to David poock nit coming over to
defend poock cuts to the front oh V sticks the pad
out and makes a huge save Meer moving to the Top
Line with kir and flipping places with brat who is
now with Jack Hughes and Tyler to fley heer to the
front here's Meer jabbing at it it's thrown toward
the front Pilot's got it behind net and he feeds
heer again Hughes takes it Luke LS Hall a sharp
angle his pass is deflected merer to the Blue Line
Miller drives in Swan got a piece it bounces for
HZ SKS the the top the ball score L puts it in tie
game brought to you by the New Jersey Lottery and
the devil's first couple of shifts they just kept
pounding away that looked like the first one hit
the post right here from Eric Hall as he chips
it someone off the crossbar is that Dawson Mercer
think it's Mercer who got there in front of Hughes
as they both whack so Dawson Mercer will get the
goal well excuse me regardless I thought Hughes
got it first third of the season in the books
27 of 82 behind us Marian gets it all the way
across sent back to the front Marian jabed out it
didn't go shaton Kirk keeps it alive long ship for
the Bruins quatra in the front centers toward
oh kick he sto again on the second effort and
he slides to get him third first period Mercer
for the Devils here in the third Bruins were in
an offside position so it's a free clearance
and a perfect pass to teamer he shoots swing
and fights it off Luke Hughes turns with space
30 seconds in overtime he gains The Zone feeds
it across Jack shoots save Swan he threw the
rebound off Swan's back and it didn't go oh oh
it's getting creative boy Jack almost banked
at home host heads the other way Jack Hughes
nice defensive play he slows him up and ties him
up allowing the Devils to gain possession yeah
I love to see it from Jack good body position
there here's J for brat as Luke Hughes changes
off brat carries Jack Hughes takes he centers
and Brat's denied by San heer still rolling and
on the puck keeps it in the offensive end he's
your turn turn for goal cuts to the front Swan
got a piece of it so it is brat Luke Hughes and
Jack Hughes Luke's going to peel off look like he
took a bit of a stick so he changes brat puts
the shoulder down he changes Direction Jack H
shoots Devil's winning
overtime that was nasty B for tough play
of the game presented by your local Ford
dealers and watch J for brat change gears as
L home it's reing but he stops up gets it to
Jack Hughes and he beats him just under
the glove over the left pad what a win
for the Devils here against one of the best
in the Boston Bruins that is your built for
tough play I just love the change of speed and
gears from Jer brat and he creates some diamond